They negotiated.
And then they negotiated some more.
Eurozone finance ministers spent a total of
eighteen hours talking.
In the end, they agreed to this:
We have agreed to enhance the role of ESM
(European Stability Mechanism) to further
strengthen the crisis prevention and resolution
capabilities of the euro area.
We will also increase the effectiveness of
ESM precautionary instruments.
At the same time, we reaffirm that ESM support
is our last resort and that we need to ensure
an appropriate level of conditionality.
In other words: more support for struggling
eurozone economies.
But the help comes with strings attached.
There was far LESS consensus on other issues
though:
Like the proposal for a joint eurozone budget
and a plan to secure all euro zone bank despoits.
Also looming over the meeting: uncertainty
over Italy's spending plans.
The country is currently REVISING its draft
budget after the EU threatened to fine it
for violating fiscal rules.
Italy's public debt now stands at more than
130 percent of GDP.
That's more than DOUBLE of what's allowed
under EU rules.
Another thing that will need
to
be talked about.